بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد يقول الحافظ
النووي رحمه الله تعالى في رياضه في كتاب
العلم في باب فضل العلم تعلما وتعليما لله
تعالى وعن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه ان رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال ومن سلك
طريقا يلتمس فيه علما من سهل الله له به
طريقا الى الجنه رواه مسلم وهذه الروايه
هي
طرف
من حديث طويل
في صحيح الامام مسلم
يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فيه
من نفس عن مؤمن كربه من كرب الدنيا
نفس الله عنه به كربه بها كربه من كرب يوم
القيامه
ومن يسر على معسر يسر الله عليه في الدنيا
والاخره
ومن ستر مسلما ستره الله في الدنيا
والله في عون العبد ما كان العبد في عون
اخيه
ومن سلك طريقا يلتمس فيه علما
سهل الله له به طريقا الى الجنه
وما اجتمع قوم في بيت من بيوت الله يتلون
كتاب الله ويتدارسونه
بينهم
الا غشيتهم الرحمه ونزلت عليهم السكينه
وحفتهم الملائكه
وذكرهم الله في من عنده
ومن
بطء به
عمله لم يسرع به نسبه او كما قال صلى الله
عليه وسلم
ومن بطا به عمله لم يسرع به نسبه
together
صحيح مسلم ابو هريره
صلى الله عليه وسلم
that
cap
of life
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏whoever
cris
upon aow believer
from the cr of this world
will use it
byeving for him a cris of the cris of
the hereaf
and whoever helps to make easy upon a
fellow believer
a difficulty
[Silence]
الله
said servant is at
‏any
الله سبحانه وتالى
زاد ما زاد
‏and
here
and
upon
to know
will make
easy for him to parading
on the ‏Now notice the person may not
necessarily learn. That's before you
even learn anything. ‏As soon as you
step on the path, you have stepped on a
direct path to parad by doing what?
Seeking knowledge. ‏me by theران
understandingران
me knowledge العلم قال رسوله قال الصحابه
هم اول العرفان
and no gr of people and thisat nop of
people
‏are
any house in any of the houses ofing
and studing
among themselves we are doing right
now this is what we are doing we are
gathered studing
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وت
‏and prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
ومن بطا به عمله لم يسرع به نسبه ايش يعني
هذا الكلام؟ يعني الذي
يكون بطيئا على الصراط يوم القيامه
لشر عمله او لذنبه او لقله سرعانه الى
الخير فان نسبه
لن يسرعه
لن يخفف عنه
الله عز وجل يصف يوم القيامه
فيقول حين ينفخ في الصور فلا انساب بينهم
يومئذ ولا
يتساءلون ولا واحد يسال الثاني وين فلان
شلون فلان حصل مع ولا واحد سائل عن الثاني
نفسي نفسي شعار ذاك اليوم والانبياء
والرسل على الصراط يقولون
اللهم سلم سلم نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
السلامه والعافيه والعفو ونساله سبحانه
وتعالى العلم والعمل اللهم ارزقنا
وهب لنا من ازواجنا وذرياتنا قره اعين
واجعلنا للمتقين اماما ربنا اتنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار اللهم انا نعوذ بك من جهد البلاء
ودرك الشقاء وسوء القضاء وشماته الاعداء
اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء ومنازل
الشهداء ومرافقه الانبياء والنصر على
الاعداء يا سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن
والعطاء وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين امين